thank you all for joining us today
uh my name is christian pasquel from uh
the wolfram research south america
team um connecting live from lima peru
one of our main projects there is the
blockchain integration so
all right so i counted like eight
presentations this tech conference
with the name what's new in x so my
title is not the most creative one but
i think it's relevant because blockchain
space is like
christmas every day there's always
something new there's always someone
doing um very interesting things
every day so i find that exciting
and that's why we have fun working on
this so what's new in blockchain i'm
going to show you
uh the stuff we are working on the stuff
we are
planning to release soon all right so
uh as you know we already have uh the
wolfram language connected to
different blockchains um
so currently we are connected to uh the
bitcoin the ethereum
and arc blockchain featuring their
maintenance devnets test nets
and we are we introduced some uh months
ago
the blocks were
um the blocks were
blockchain so this is a blockchain uh
for
scientific research it was founded by
the max planck
society and there's uh other
institutions
uh in this consortium and so we all
we do all these integrations through our
company well from blockchain labs and
so we work on connecting with blockchain
group blockchain companies
and connecting our technology and
basically
following our philosophy of injecting
computational
intelligence um into the blockchain
space
all right so let me show you what
we have here for
blacksburg i'll make this a little bit
bigger all right
if you are wondering bloxber they use
all lowercase that's why
i don't write this like this like it as
this uh
all right so all the uh wolfram
blockchain functions you already love
uh work with uh with this blockchain
so let's see there's some uh basic
information about
bloxburg so this is a blockchain based
on ethereum it's actually an ethereum
fork
and they change it a little bit uh they
modify the uh consensus algorithm
and other things uh we probably see here
all right so let's try something like
blockchain block data so with blockchain
block data you get information
from the blog so let's try blog 5150
and yeah something cool i i like about
this blockchain is that you can
actually see names here so
instead of miners they have something
they call validators
it's one of these um many institutions
related to to the blacksburg
uh blockchain so we have something like
this and i should have
here a block from other institution
let's see as you can
uh see here if you already
don't know you can use a blockchain
block uh
data function with a block height or a
block hash
like in this case yeah you can see here
the university of applied science
highland and
yeah and so all our functions are
uh integrated with the um block
blocks blockchain so you can do
anything you can do with other
blockchains you can do with blockspur
personal favorite example of mine is
doing some sounds with block data let's
see if this works
so you're you're here in a blocker
and yeah
i feel like judy foster in the contact
movie listening for aliens
all right so uh what else we can
explore um transactions so
i should have here a block with some
transactions
and let's get the transaction list
property they will return this will
return at least after section so we'll
just do a random choice of one
of these and let's say this is
transaction
id all right so let's try the
blockchain transaction data function
id and we should see some um
yeah the information about uh the of
lottery transactions so
as with other blockchains we try to make
everything computable so you see like
here the timestamp
is is a time object and we also
support their cryptocurrency so that
their native
cryptocurrencies called brock's and
well this is kind of boring because it's
just zero blocks so let's try something
um all right so let's try the blockchain
address
data that's in our of our functions
and this one should have more
information yeah all right so this one
has um
a balance so if i
oops
so if i do this and ask
for the balance i can show you here
that uh yeah this is a quantity with
blocks as units one
single detail about this is that if you
to you try to do something like currency
convert
um from blocks to
let's say anything like bitcoins
uh you'll get a fail message because
uh blocks don't have a real
uh word value so our quantity and
currency framework uh only
deal with quantities that have real
value so like if you do something
let's say do you blockchain block data
but in this case we'll use the
let's say the arc blockchain
this one has um yeah
so let's see so art blockchain works
with their
cryptocurrency called arc so if i try
something
like this let's
the currency convert of
arctosis to bitcoins
and these should work fine because
arcs do have a value in in the real
world
but if i do let's say arc and
get something from their
def net
so for their def net they use a
different kind of
uh units instead of arcs they use darks
i like that name
and so darks are something like
um like testnet uh bitcoins
so they don't have a real value and you
will get the same
error message uh all right so going back
to blocks where
they also have uh tokens
so when we started um
working with blocks were i remember they
only had like some
basic example tokens like abcdef and
the rest of the alphabet but i believe
they have more things now so let's try
to
make a work cloud of their tokens based
on their transfers count
yeah so yeah now they have um
yeah they don't have more tokens so i
encourage you to go to
uh their website and
learn more about this project and
then go back to wolfram language and try
that with
with our functions and our integration
so this is already available in 12.1
uh the documentation uh will be included
in 12 2. all right so
i was telling you that we do all these
things uh through world from blockchain
lab so
uh we talk to a company and we do some
kind of partnership
and integrate our technologies but what
about if you have your
own blockchain and you want to connect
to uh you want to connect you want to
integrate your blockchain
to the world front language so if you
are familiar with
stuff like let's say the function
repository
um
yeah where you can
you can submit functions to to the
uh to the function repository or the
data repository
uh so you'll be a little bit familiar
with what we are
uh planning to release soon that is a
framework to connect
to your blockchain and integrate the
the blockchain functions we have um
with your blockchain so for that what
you need is say
uh is to expose your blockchain through
an api
so i should have here let's see
yeah so i made this fake api to
uh yes as an example and
with this i can i can show you how this
works
so yeah i just added some three basic
endpoints
uh simulating data from the blockchain
so like if i do
something so this endpoint
should return information from
from a block so if i do something like
girl
and provide a parameter let's say
5150 yeah and this returns
some json data about that that block
and if i try this it should return
information from that transactions
in this block let's see yeah
this is this is working all right so
let's go back
to this notebook and
and try to connect to these
um this blockchain so let's
let's call this yes uh wealthy coin
and by the way so we try to make this as
easy as possible
you don't even need to be an expert in
world from language to to connect to
your blockchain
uh it's better if you're familiar with
apis but we even have uh
yeah we have a sample notebook here that
you can use to
um yeah you can follow as a reference to
just
fill out the the fields and and all that
um
all right so let's try this
so this thing is asking me for a base
url that's basically the
uh this part of the url that is not
changing and that should be
let me copy and paste this
here all right so i have my uh base url
uh you can add more
uh details here and you have some
helpers like a
link to the blockchain documentation uh
but let's go to to this part so
what i'm doing here is i'm going to
connect to these endpoints
i i created before and
all right so i have the got to connect
to this
block endpoint to get information about
a block
so since i'm getting the
uh the raw data uh i'll just call this i
i use this
internal uh notation for
uh raw requests so let's call this raw
block data the path to
this endpoint is just block which is
basically just
this part here and what else i need a
parameter that it's also called block
they
it's same name but they are actually
different things so
this is the end point and this is a
parameter so yeah don't get confused
but i think that's everything i need to
connect to that endpoint so i click
save here all right so
okay let's try this so if i do something
like
raw block data
argument name that's block
and let's try 150
yeah so i i'm getting i'm getting a
result here
all right but if you see this
um you'll see that we only have
uh partially from information from the
block i also want to add
um the transaction list of
of this block so for that i need a
second endpoint the one i
show you here so i can go here and say
at endpoint now i'm going to call these
let's say raw block transaction
data and this end point
is called let's see it's
uh block
transactions the query parameter
is i can block so it's
basically this endpoint here and this
parameter
so all right let's try this
okay so if i go here
so let's try raw block transaction
data all right yeah it's returning uh
data so
am i done i'm not done because i just
connected to
uh to the raw data from the blockchain
what i
really want to do is integrate this with
the wolfram language
so we'll have a section as you can see
here
blockchain transaction data i'm just
using blockchain data as an example
we'll have a section for
each of our blockchain functions so the
idea is that you get the raw
data from the blockchain and then
follow our standards to display
a nice computable output so yeah let's
try that
so for that um i already have this so i
need to
complete this this this definition which
is
uh yes as easy as um defining
any functions if i do something like
module
and all right let's see so
i want data from the block so it's going
to be blocked data
and block data is going to come from
this endpoint
yeah i'm not use i'm not using a fixed
uh block but i'm using this parameter
and i'm also getting the block
uh whatever transaction data
that comes from this endpoint here
i'm going to change this to block all
right so i think this
this is all i need to uh get the raw
data so
now the only thing i have to do is um
build my output using the
yeah the standard things uh we use in
our functions like
um using a camel case
value for the keys computable
data for the values if possible so let's
say i'm going to
call this the block id and that's going
to use from
block data that's going to use let's see
the property hash
so if i do something like hash
all right so i have the block id i also
want to display
let's call this a block number that
comes from the
height property these are just
numbers or hashes so let's do something
more
interesting like the timestamp so if you
see the timestamp
here you'll see it's just a
regular uh unix time
but we don't return uh unix time
here but we return a computable version
so uh
uh date or time object so i'll do
something like from phoenix time
uh what else um so since i invented this
blockchain and i'm a fan of dune instead
of
miner i'm going to call this maker
and all right so i'm going to extract
this from the
maker
field and what else all right so i'm
getting all this from
one end point and i need one last piece
of
information that comes from the
transaction
data so i'm going to create a
transaction list here
and do block transaction data and the
name of this
field is the x list
all right dx list and
i think that's it so
let's try this all right so
[Music]
if i try this with
one block
uh yeah that's that's working but this
is
still not exactly what we want because
so if you remember when you do something
like blockchain block data
i'm going to use these and blockchain
base
goes to arc so with the blockchain based
option you
choose uh what blockchain you are going
to
to use so instead of running something
like this
what i really want is integrating this
with the
uh with functions so
once i submit this connection to my
volte coin blockchain i should have an
object and use it here as a blockchain
base and let's try
and come on come on
yeah well that worked that that's pretty
cool and let me just
use something real quick i haven't
tested these so this
will probably fail but let's try so if i
ask for a
specific property transaction list with
my new blockchain base
um
well the work that's awesome all right
so
this is something we are going to have
uh soon
so you can you'll be able to connect to
your
to your blockchain and yeah you should
be hear from us
soon too about how we are using um
our functions or technology to
uh like do some blockchain analyses
exploring blockchain data and doing some
yeah doing some cool stuff with uh all
these blockchains we are integrating
with with the welcome language
and
yeah so thank you very much for
joining us today um
now i think we have like 10 minutes for
questions you can also connect with me
on social media
we have a networking reception later in
our high fidelity virtual space
and don't forget that tomorrow we have a
cryptography uh talk from daria
boretzner who is also from our team
that's also related to our
work in in the blockchain space so
thank you very much again and i think i
have to go
to the compatible
chat if you have questions or you can
raise your hand in the zoom
um yeah you can raise your hand in this
consume and
i think we can open the mic uh for you
you have any questions
oh thank you uh well we have any
platform new blog
public blockchain yeah we we are working
on uh
uh integrating a new uh big
blockchain and we are constantly talking
to
uh companies and blockchain groups
to yeah to integrate their their public
blockchains
so yeah you'll you'll hear from that
soon too
well that's a uh great question jonathan
uh we are working
on a blockchain course for world from
you
and that's a very um
extended course because it's not it not
only covers
the technical parts of blockchain
technology
but also uh the economics and
social part so
so yeah that's uh that's something you
you can
uh use once we release that i hope that
will be
that will be soon uh if not you can
connect with me and i'm happy to provide
uh material and resources to
learn more about this technology but
this course will be
pretty cool so yeah i hope that that
would be useful
so that will be available through
wolfram u
so that's if you go to world from you
um once we release the course you should
be able to
see that here and so we are we're
planning to release
that course as soon as possible yeah
also if you go to the world from
blockchain labs
i think i can paste this on compatible
so if you go if you are there you will
be um
yeah you can also get news and stuff
about the the work we are doing
and just in case you didn't take note
this is a wall front view
website all right so if there are no
more
questions again feel free to connect
with me
um later during the networking event
or yeah you can find me on
linkedin or other social medias so
um
yeah yeah feel free to to connect uh
yeah you can find me with my name there
i guess there are no more questions uh
again thank you very much
oh a learning workflow pages mathematica
for blockchain
uh yes we have some some of them
uh let me see i have an
outdated version yeah but we do have um
workflows for let's
check that right now
let's try it guys
yeah so yeah we have this kind of
uh workflows we have for bitcoin for
arc and ethereum and
we are actually producing more of these
um
yeah so you can see more more of this
here we have the cryptography workflows
as well
but we are constantly producing
uh content for for documentation
and for other stuff that shows our
technology and
makes this easy for our users
and i think the the i remember seeing uh
translated version of this uh in
japanese so
yeah do you prefer to read that in
japanese i
remember we have that available too
yeah so for for the for the new
blockchain
framework and the definition notebook uh
we'll definitely have a
workflow and we plan to do a
video tutorial and everything we can to
make this easy for users to
integrate the the blockchains yes
all right i think we can end the meeting
now um
well again thank you very much